apples basic iPad has been updated for
2019 and while I'm still a little bit
disappointed with it for a couple of
reasons it's actually still the best
choice for people who need a basic but
very reliable tablet
the one thing Apple always upgrades with
each iPad update is the processor so I
was honestly shocked when I heard it's
packing the same 810 fusion chip from
last year's iPad but then I started to
think about why Apple would do this and
has started to make more sense to me
I'll explain why in a minute
now if you guys saw my video titled do
not buy the new 10.2 inch iPad I want to
explain the two reasons why I said that
first off the 810 chip is a lot slower
than the 812 and the new iPad Mini or
iPad air so I recommended users who want
a bit more power to spend the extra cash
on those iPads instead and the second
reason was that the nine point seven
inch iPad from 2018 was actually on sale
on Amazon brand-new for only 250 dollars
which is a much better deal for basic
iPad users since you get the same eight
n chip but now that sale is gone and
they're basically all sold out so with
that said the 10.2 inch iPad for three
hundred and twenty-nine dollars is now
currently the best deal for a reliable
budget tablet unless you're okay with a
much smaller screen if you pay just
fifty-five dollars more you can buy the
2019 iPad Mini five using the link in
the description which actually has a ton
of advantages over the budget iPad like
much better display quality the much
faster 812 chip and 64 gigabytes of
storage instead of only 32 on the basic
iPad the only reason I wouldn't buy the
iPad Mini is if either you don't want to
spend the extra cash for more
performance you don't want a small
display or if you want to use a
full-size keyboard with your iPad if you
haven't already seen our full comparison
of the 10.2 inch iPad 2 the iPad Mini 5
I recommend that you watch it by
clicking the button at the end of this
video now before I talk about why Apple
would keep the H on fusion chip for
another year let me first mention what's
new or what's not with the 2019 iPad the
biggest and most obvious change is the
large display but it didn't expect the
iPad itself to get so much bigger in
fact it's the same exact size as the
2019 iPad air and just like the air the
regular iPad now gets
smart connector so it supports the same
exact keyboard as air as well the only
problem is that it's $159 for that
keyboard and I can't imagine that most
people looking for a budget iPad will be
willing to spend that much more money
just for a keyboard it is currently on
sale for a hundred forty three dollars
on Amazon which is nice but it's still
really expensive a better choice for
people on a budget is this Bluetooth
keyboard case for only $39 I'll drop a
link to it down in the description below
other than that the only other
differences I've noticed were a bump up
to three gigabytes of RAM and improved
speaker quality besides that everything
else is basically the same the same 810
fusion chip as I've mentioned before the
same support for the first gen Apple
pencil the same 32 gigs of base storage
the same old Bluetooth 4.2 the same non
laminated display with a lack of
contrast gap between the display and
glass and high reflectivity so compared
to last year's iPad there really isn't
that much new this year but that's not
necessarily a bad thing now let me
explain why Apple would keep the 810
fusion chip around for another year the
budget $329 iPad was always meant to be
the budget tablet option for people who
need a basic tablet for regular tasks
like browsing the web using web-based
apps watching videos on YouTube
streaming shows and movies using the
Apple pencil for note-taking and
casually playing basic games on the App
Store and for all those things the a10
fusion chip is more than powerful enough
and Apple knows that basic iPad users
won't have any issues especially since
they added another gigabyte of RAM to
make sure the new multitasking in iPad
OS works smoothly but for the kind of
user who needs to do more serious work
on their iPad like advanced photo and
video editing or if they're planning to
play the highest end games available the
$329 iPad won't cut it and that's why
they have the higher-end iPads like the
iPad Mini and the iPad air which packed
the a12 chip and the iPad pro with the a
12 X and since there really isn't that
big of a difference in performance
between the a 11 chip and the a 12 there
would be a really huge boost in
performance if Apple packed the a 11
instead of the 810 in the budget iPad
there wouldn't be much of a reason to
spend more cash on the higher-end
iPads and that's what Apple chose to
stick with the a-10 for another year
until their other iPads are upgraded to
the a13 chip there's also a downside to
the three year old a10 ship that most
people don't think about starting with
the a11 Bionic chip Apple implemented
the knurl engine which powers machine
learning and augmented reality
applications that neural engine is
completely missing on the a10 so if and
when machine learning becomes more
common or if more augmented reality apps
come to the App Store those apps may run
significantly slower on this budget iPad
compared to the higher-end models so
that's something to think about I think
the biggest question most people are
having is how long this iPad will
continue to receive software support
seeing as the a-10 chip is already three
years old at this time in my opinion
since iPad OS is now its own separate
entity I think Apple will support the
2019 budget iPad for the next five years
as usual even though there's a chance
they might stop supporting the a10
packing iPhone 7 sooner than that
for example the iPhone 6 with the a8
chip doesn't support iOS 13 well the
iPad Mini 4 with that same a 8 chip does
support the new iPad OS so all in all
the 2019 10.2 inch iPad is still the
iPad to get if you're on a budget or if
you just need a basic iPad to do regular
things it's gonna be reliable for years
to come and that's what truly matters
when you're buying a tablet and if
you're struggling to choose between this
iPad and some of the higher-end models
check out that comparison video right
there to see all the differences and if
you enjoy this review click that circle
above to subscribe thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]